On a very symbolic day, Christmas 1991, the
flag of the Soviet Union was pulled down from
the Kremlin's flagpole once and for all.
It was the end of an era that had lasted almost
70 years.
That evening pretty much every tv news broadcasted
live the resignation speech of the last secretary
of the Soviet Communist Party: Mikhail Gorbachev.
The first international reaction was that
of the US President George Bush Senior who,
for three times, described the event as America's
definitive victory over communism.
However, the question that many asked themselves
at the time was: how had it been possible
to get to that point?
The collapse of the Soviet Union was a sequence
of causes.
Internal and external, old and rotten, all
typical causes of a crippled system, magnified
by a sequence of major errors.
To discuss the collapse we must go back a
few years earlier, to November 1982.
Gorbachev wasn't yet the General Secretary
of the Communist Party.
That role was held by Jurij Andropov.
To be honest, the idea of "restructuring"
the Soviet Union did not start with Gorbachev.
But with Andropov.
Many in Russia were saying: if only Andropov
had lived a little longer, the USSR would
have survived.
Well, when he was appointed by Brezhnev as
his successor, Andropov was aware that he
was inheriting a Soviet Union full of problems.
By 1982, the Soviets were at war with Afghanistan,
détente with the West had failed, and Reagan
- an anti-communist champion - had ascended
to the White House.
In Eastern Europe, things weren't any better:
in Poland, workers were demanding a decrease
in food prices and, with the help of dissident
intellectuals, they had founded a movement
of revolt, Solidarity, which in the early
eighties already had millions of members.
The problems, however, were not "fresh" ones:
the USSR had many open questions since its
foundation, and one of these can be ascribed
to one single word: historical instability.
Since the time of the Revolution, Socialism
in Russia claimed to be able to modernize
a nation that, unlike Western Europe, was
still trapped in economic and political chaos.
It was like playing a strategy video game:
pick the USSR and you get a starting handicap
compared to other Western nations.
This starting handicap generated an immature
and unripe condition for the communists in
power, which made them force the stages of
a modernization process that had taken centuries
in the West.
To put it in even more basic terms that will
piss off any chef living in Italy, they wanted
to make pasta by boiling it in still lukewarm
water.
For some, the Soviet Union was created on
unstable foundations: an economy torn apart
by the incapacity of the imperial government,
working classes that were really still underdeveloped
and the absence of really decisive cultural
movements.
This condition of intrinsic failings of the
system, would persist throughout the whole
Soviet history.
Sure, with Stalin, heavy industrialization
and increased centralization brought changes
in the economy, they were a decisive impulse
to transform the Soviet Union into a nation
no longer backward, the second most industrial
nation in the world, yet the latent problems
didn't disappear, they only festered: the
majority population were no longer peasants
but workers.
Goodbye, Kulaks.
And with both Stalin and his successors Krushev
and Brezhnev, the economy was dictated by
a single key word: intensity...
when in fact the Soviets needed the opposite,
extensivity.
I’m not sure if this word exists in English.
To beat the West, the USSR adopted the mantra
of quantity over quality.
Although far from the American model, the
Soviet one would always be based on a "Fordist"
conception, let's say, where almost everyone
ended up in a factory working to contribute
to the huge production of materials, first
for war and then for civilian use.
And it remained so, even when in the rest
of the Western world, in the 80s, the arrival
of a new technology began to be foreseen:
information technology.
As promoters of a socialist model, the big
problem of the Soviets was being immediately
subjected to a very strong political isolation
and economic embargoes by that advanced part
of the world, the West.
The Soviet Union was indeed autonomous, but
ended up being a separate universe on its
own.
In the 80's, Andropov was the first to realize
that in order to modernize the Soviet economy
there were a need for money and knowledge
that was abundant in the West.
This idea obviously didn’t diminish the
value and the quality of many Soviet scientists,
but it rather diminished the immobility that
for decades marked the Communist Party.
As Andropov confessed in 1981 to Erich Mielke,
head of the Stasi - the East German secret
service: "The Americans seem to have unlimited
money".
Andropov had a point: NATO, Japan and the
Arab states of the Gulf contributed to financing
the American debt and its state funds, including
military spending; on the other hand, the
Soviet Union had a whole series of socialist
states that depended exclusively on subsidies
from Mother Moscow.
The isolation of the socialist countries had
contributed to making it clear to everyone
that it was capitalism that was dictating
the rules of the game, and the fact that with
détente in the 1970s the Soviet Union had
taken up the idea of opening a dialogue with
the United States, and thus knocking on the
door of those who controlled the capitalist
market, was - to use the words of Eric Hobsbawm
- the beginning of the end.
The first signs of weakness in the Soviet
Union appeared in 1979, when the international
markets were hit by a very serious oil crisis.
The wave fell with all its power on the Soviet
budgets that relied heavily on the export
of gas and crude oil.
The USSR was in fact the first oil producing
nation, with more than eleven million barrels
per day).
But it was another energy crisis that messed
up the game, not that of 79 but that of 73.
In that year, a West without oil decided to
renew itself technically and scientifically
so to make itself less dependent on crude
oil exporting countries and at the same time
find new ways of earning money; Russia, instead,
was satisfied to export oil to Western countries
and had no incentive to innovate itself.
At a meeting in 1982 Andropov denounced a
very disturbing fact: the Soviets were importing
more and more food such as grain and meat
from foreign countries.
Andropov said "I don't wanna alarm you," "but,"
he continued, "in the last few years we have
wasted billions of rubles.
Strong words, strong words from a strange
man, though in reality he was right, because
instead of using oil revenues to invest them
in technology and knowledge for development,
the Soviet Union used them to do what it should
not do: import food - that it could produce
very well by itself - and give subsidies to
its puppet states.
The United States did nothing but say thanks.
With the oil crisis in 79, the Russians found
themselves with no money left to pay for food
imports.
At that point what did they do?
They started borrowing money from Western
foreigners themselves.
The first to experience the mechanism of debt
on their own skin were the countries of Eastern
Europe, the Baltics but especially Romania,
Poland and Hungary, where the need to repay
foreign debt increased social unrest, which,
in turn, led to popular uprisings that slowly
brought Eastern Europe away from Soviet control.
The first countries to incur debts with the
International Monetary Fund were Yugoslavia,
which was no longer aligned with Moscow, and
then it was the turn of the friends in the
Warsaw Pact.
Already in 1970 Moscow found itself surrounded
by satellite states with negative budgets
and with pockets full of debts with the West.
When a group of dissidents created Solidarnosc
in Poland in 1980, Andropov became aware of
one thing: the inability to intervene militarily
as USSR had done with Czechoslovakia in 1968.
Moreover, the underlying problem wasn't tangible,
the problem was the absence of money.
As pointed out by historian Vladislav Zubok:
Poland had accumulated $27 billion in debt
to Western banks at very high interest rates
and, for its part, the Soviets did not have
the capital to repay the debts of the Poles.
The Russians were well aware of the implications
of this: their own satellite states had become
the weak links that risked blowing up COMECON,
the economic alliance within the Union republics.
In an investigation by Carl Bernstein, a journalist
known for having contributed to the unraveling
of the Watergate scandal in America, it was
reported that Solidarnosc was nothing more
than a tool in the hands of the United States
and financed by the italian bank Banco Ambrosiano
– in connection with the Vatican - to undermine
the USSR from within.
Nothing new on the Western front: Actually
the exact quote from the book is “All quiet
on the Western Front”.
it's just that in Italian we say that way
and I translated it literally.
Mamma mia.
the Vatican hoped to take root not only in
the very religious Poland but also in the
rest of Eastern Europe; and the United States,
well, needless to say: they wanted to win
the race.
As Bernestein reported, the U.S. embassy in
the Polish capital of Warsaw had in fact become
the CIA headquarters on the other side of
the Iron Curtain.
Undoubtedly, in Poland there were already
discontents, the citizens were very suffering,
otherwise it would have been impossible for
the western secret services to create such
massive riots out of nothing.
The use secret services was common on both
sides; nuclear weapons forced to act in the
background.
And speaking of nuclear armaments, there are
those who say that the arms race and the military
spending budget contributed to the Soviet
imbalance.
According to Mark Harrison, professor and
expert in Economic History, it was not military
spending that endangered the Soviet economy.
In terms of numbers, the active personnel
in the Soviet Union in the 80's amounted to
more than 5 million and 12% of the GDP was
dedicated to the budget for the war industry;
in comparison, the maximum that the United
States had done was in 1963, when they allocated
9% of GDP.
The United States, having a greater number
of allies at its disposal and therefore more
resources to draw on, could tolerate with
more ease this competition which, at the end
was aimed at frantically bleeding the Soviet
coffers, something that the Secretary of State
George Schulz himself would later admit.
In the 80's, when Reagan threated the USSR
with the installation of the Euro missiles,
the Soviets had to intensify their efforts
by running after advanced technologies and
creating an arsenal of more than 6000 nuclear
warheads, a huge strain for the weak Soviet
economy that generated irreparable imbalances.
In fact, since Stalin took the leadership,
the Soviet economy had been based on a state
of permanent war and neurosis, and this had
pushed the Russians to prefer heavy industry
- first of all war and industrial machineries
- at the expense of consumer goods.
And as if that weren't enough, despite Kosygin's
unsuccessful attempts to reform the economy
in the 1960s, Soviet planning - which was
centralized and state-based - had serious
cracks in it: false and inaccurate information,
inflated production costs, excess materials
produced without accounting for the real quantities
needed, low labor productivity, low rhythms,
absenteeism, and poorly exploited labor.
All this only widened the gap with the overly
competitive capitalist world.
If you were a Soviet worker, whether you worked
hard 10 hours a day or not, that salary always
came.
So why make an unnecessary effort?
The same happened with the salaries of all
the professions (from doctors to engineers)
which, since Krushov in the 60's, had been
fixed at a predetermined ceiling beyond which
they rarely went.
It is logical that without the possibility
of economic progress, one does not have the
incentive to get better.
Practical examples such as these generated
over the decades a loss of confidence in socialism
by the Soviets.
In the 1970s and 1980s in Russia, as reported
by historian Zaslavsky, workers were passive,
indifferent, lacking ideals and driven by
purely consumerist behavior, a pessimism also
intensified by the failure of the invasion
of Afghanistan.
Society had entered a labyrinth of economic
and social crises.
The same Soviet companies, subsidized by the
State, did not aim at technological innovation
and investment, because nothing would change.
In a nation where little food, few medicines,
few clothes or household appliances were produced,
things were bound to get jammed up.
With the crisis of 1979, the distribution
of essential supplies became more and more
complex.
When, under Gorbachev at the end of the 1980s,
food prices conformed to those of the Western
free market, the damage was complete and empty
shelves in supermarkets became the norm in
Russia.
Another internal issue that had been building
up since the Fifties in the Soviet Union then
deepened the crisis of essential goods.
The Double Economy.
Today we would call it "the black economy",
a shadow economy, parallel to the state economy
and composed of transactions that went under
the scanner of the Soviet bureaucracy.
In short, the Double Economy deprived the
State of revenue, making it flow into the
black market.
Goods such as cars, for which there were very
long waiting lists, were an excellent opportunity
on which many bureaucrats speculated, by reselling
them on the black market at very high prices.
This involved any item: furniture, spare parts,
clothes and even houses construction.
The black market meant that, in addition to
money, materials and labor were being stolen
from the state.
Over time, all over the USSR - especially
the areas most remote from Moscow - an underworld
of businessmen - whom the historian Zubok
calls pseudo-capitalists - had formed.
These were real entrepreneurs with money,
materials and workers.
They contolled all of this under the table
to raise more money and earn more than the
standard salary offered by the State.
Konstantin Simis in his book "The Secret World
of Soviet Capitalism" states: "Under the socialist
surface lies a network of private companies.
Thousands of them produce sweaters, shoes,
sunglasses, cassettes with Western pop music,
handbags and many other goods.
The owners are both small businessmen and
multimillionaire family clans holding dozens
of companies."
When Gorbachev came to power in '85, no politician
or bureaucrat was exempt from this under-the-table
trafficking.
The underground economy, which in the 60's
was equivalent to 3% of the national economy,
in the 90's in the Soviet Union reached 13%.
Prostitution and drugs also contributed to
a large part of the Soviet underground economy.
It was in this illegality that corruption
and the Mafias found very fertile ground.
Already in 1974, among the highest Party officials,
the Moscow Mafia had profitable business relations.
With the fierce privatizations in the early
90's the Russian Mafia found a real treasure;
that was the period when organized crime became
the true master of the streets, the dispenser
of death and violence for millions of Russians
who fell into the Abìss of drug addiction.
. And unlike his predecessors who at least
tried to hide things, Gorbachev instilled
the idea of a lost war; he was the first to
say in his speeches that capitalism won, and
communism didn't.
Attitude of a true leader.
Many blamed the Soviet nomenklatura and bureaucracy
who enjoyed special privileges and lived as
if they were a class of their own.
State inertia, excessive bureaucratization
and the indifference of Party members had
created a huge gap between citizens and politics.
The politicians themselves were so old that
they were referred to as a "gerontocracy,"
a government of elders bloated by nepotism
and cronyism.
And clearly when the old guys are in power,
all gathered into one party, they only care
about keeping that power until they die.
What about improving the economy?
Pff who damn cares?
In the Soviet Union there were two nomenklatures:
the political-administrative one, which permeated
the single Party in Moscow, and the economic
one made up of military, intellectuals and
business managers.
That the two sides were separated was not
a good thing.
Because when the central state - hence the
bureaucrats in Moscow - increasingly weakened
by the scarcity of money and consumer goods
began to lose relevance and influence in the
country, the power passed more and more into
the hands of the economic nomenklatura, that
is those who actually held the real resources
of the country: directors who managed industries,
estates and mines, the same ones who later,
with the fierce sell-off of the best national
companies, would turn into multi-billionaire
oligarchs.
In the liberal years of Gorbachev, the "economic
nomenklatura" chose to play with intelligence,
opening private companies and joint ventures
with Western partners, by giving them valuable
information previously kept by party bureaucrats.
And that wasn’t all: they also offered most
of their resources that the Soviet Union enjoyed
in abundance, such as oil and gas.
Everything officially started with the famous
Perestrojka, literally "the reconstruction".
Perestroika proved one thing: that the breakup
of the USSR, before Gorbachev, was not a foregone
conclusion.
Gorbachev - who is still alive and is 90 years
old - has yet to be fully analysed by historians.
For the moment I will always remember him
for his awkward commercial [...] Essentially
with that appearance which was paid 1 million
dollars, Gorby implicitly admitted in front
of everyone that consumerism was superior
to the ideology of its own party.
The funny thing was that Gorbachev always
invoked Lenin's name in his rallies, he considered
him a mentor, but perestroika, initially presented
as something revolutionary, ended up becoming
the opposite, the dismantling of the whole
system.
The slogan was "acceleration", recovering
the gap with the West.
But in order to do so, Gorbachev implemented
his reforms on the basis of two conditions
that would have got Lenin's hair fall - at
least the remaining ones: de-statalization,
i'm not sure if this word exists in English,
and privatization.
According to some historians, Gorbachev acted
consciously, he wanted to dismantle the Soviet
system piece by piece, to embrace the dogmas
of economic liberalism, deceived by the benefits
of economic exchange with the West.
For others, Gorbachev was simply an idiot
who had no idea how to lead a country.
He instead admitted that he was convinced
that it wasn’t possible to reform the country
without first dismantling it, making it transparent
and free from the maniacal control of state
censorship, hence the concept of Glasnost'.
Glasnost was in fact the sounding board of
the disaster of perestroika, because the media
began to talk about those problems in Russia
that were under the eyes of all but no one
could mention: alcoholism, lack of food and
crumbling housing.
And speaking of alcohol: the drinking habit
of Russians is well known, to the point of
being a social plague.
Gorbachev thought it was time to eradicate
the problem by implementing an anti-alcohol
policy.
The catch was, however, that alcohol taxes
guaranteed the state a sum of about six hundred
and sixty-six million dollars.
However, the Gosplan, the State Planning Committee
- under pressure from Gorbachev himself - cut
off that source of revenue, raising drink
prices and prosecuting those caught in a...
well, miserable state.
Nonetheless, the ban didn't take into account
a detail: the black market.
The vodka that became a luxury good ended
up again "m3rachiulusly" resold through the
back door.
The financial disaster was quick to come:
sales of vodka dropped from 54 billion rubles
in 1984 to 11 billion in 1986.
In Gorbachev's mind, however, there were no
issues: this is it, in 5 years we'll heal
USSR.
Gorbachev reasoned by taking as a model what
happened in the 30s: at that time, the USSR
had begun to modernize thanks to the construction
of industries and plants erected by Western
companies that, on commission, had also trained
Soviet engineers and workers from scratch.
One example above all was the American architect
Albert Kahn, who joined the Kremlin's consulting
team for the construction of more than five
hundred industrial plants; another example
was the General Electric, which oversaw the
construction of the hydroelectric power plant
on the Dniepr River.
Instead, Gorbachev's mistake was to channel
money into existing state enterprises, not
to create new ones.
The old leaders were conservative, unwilling
to innovate.
And that's why much of the equipment that
had been purchased in the West was never used
in the old plants.
Brilliant.
Anyway, whatever plans Gorbachev and his team
of economists had for the long term...
well, the Chernobyl nuclear disaster in April
86 erased them altogether.
The flight of hundreds of thousands of people
from the surrounding areas evoked scenarios
from World War II.
According to the head of the economic department
Nikolai Ryzhkov, the cost of the Chernobyl
disaster for the first month alone was 8 billion
rubles.
To paraphrase Ryzhkov, Chernobyl delivered
a devastating blow to the Soviet economy.
People began to whisper that it was the " tainted
leader", Gorbachev, to bring bad luck... he
was called in that disdainful way because
of the visible spot on his forehead.
Gorbachev did not make himself very popular,
as he kept the entire Russian population in
the dark about the disaster for many days.
Apart from Chernobyl, Gorbachev went on with
his Perestroika, and what were the results?
Terrible.
Perestroika liberalized overnight a Soviet
economy that was planned from the beginning,
it was a devastating blow.
First, government officials approved the creation
of "free" prices, no longer controlled and
set by the state.
Only 4% of the citizens approved this maneuver.
The result?
A race to the top of basic necessities and
a hyperinflation that in 1992 would have touched
peaks of Two Thousand Six Hundred %. Money
was rationed and in its place a sort of "consumer
card" was introduced, they were sheets of
paper worth various amounts of rubles, with
which citizens could make purchases without
using cash money.
When they found a piece of bread after hours
standing in line, Russians could count themselves
lucky if they could buy a half-pound loaf
of bread for 6 dollars, compared to an average
monthly salary of fifty dollars.
Although the Soviet standard of living until
then had always been at least a third lower
than that of Westerners, citizens noticed
the difference with respect to previous times:
crime, especially the mafia, was lower and
there was a general sense of greater security.
Whether this was real or not is another story.
With Perestroika there was a free-for-all
for those who wanted to do business with large
foreign multinationals, an incentive from
which stemmed a whole series of speculation
and fake sales, like the ones of the strategic
Soviet mining companies at symbolic prices.
On top of that, there was the Issuance of
new currencies for all the republics of the
Union.
This increased the confusion of internal transactions
and trade.
In addition, the so-called "property law"
of 1990, which removed the state from ownership
of key industries, generated 2 million unemployed
nationwide, a figure never seen before.
And as we know, an unemployed population use
more and more alcohol and drugs, to say the
least.
By 98, the Russian economy, in the hands of
mobsters and foreign entrepreneurs, would
have been almost completely halved from 1990
figures, going from a GDP of five hundred
and ten billion to a GDP of two hundred and
seventy.
Food prices had doubled, and wages were less
than half.
While, typhoid, cholera and other diseases
had reached epidemic proportions in the country.
It was as if the entire nation had suddenly
gone back 80 years.
Some, such as historian Stephen Cohen, have
called this achievement the result of a particular
phenomenon, Gangster Capitalism.
The opening up to international markets also
encouraged the arrival of private banks, which
replaced the monopoly of the State Bank.
Soviet debt to Western banks jumped from twenty
seven point two billion dollars in 1985 to
forty billion $ in 1986.
Wanting to reform things too quickly also
invested the political front.
Gorbachev knew that the Party - and its members
- were the operational core.
If he wanted to change the Union structure,
the only way was to strip Party members of
their various Departments and deprive them
of their powers.
With a series of reforms Gorbachev did just
that, he took away the Party's decision-making
monopoly.
In doing so, however, it was like beheading
the State, it was a political suicide, in
all respects.
Without a head - the State - the body (the
Soviet Union) suddenly stopped working, a
bit like unplugging a device.
At that point, all it took was a little push,
an international event of great impact that
could maybe break up the entire Eastern bloc.
Oh, yeah, how silly, this already happened
in 1989: --- With the symbolic fall of the
Berlin Wall, like a domino, all the Soviet
republics, starting with the Baltic ones,
broke away one after the other in the wake
of the independence euphoria that horrified
the Russian nationalists.
And nationalism was the final card, the ace
of spades that would close the game.
The first to realize that the rules of that
game were changing, was Boris Yeltsin.
Like an old fox, Yeltsin exploited the frustrations
of the most radical communists and some of
the members of the secret service to break
away from Gorbachev's wing, dress up as a
populist leader, go into opposition, and support
a coup against Gorbachev in 1991 in the capital
Moscow.
The images of him getting on the tank would
go around the world, angering the most dissatisfied
people who were fed up with Gorbachev's policies.
The coup failed immediately, because obviously
there was no longer a state.
It must be said that 70% of the population
wanted to maintain the Soviet Union, the referendum
on the preservation of the USSR in 1991 clearly
demonstrated this.
But these were not Yeltsin's plans.
Yeltsin had all the popular support to be
able to obscure Gorbachev, take away his remaining
consensus and force him to resign at the end
of August.
In November of the same year Yeltsin would
issue a decree with which to make illegal
any activity of the Communist Party and dissolve
once and for all the Soviet State.
On December 11, 1991 only two of the 15 Soviet
republics were still part of the Union: Russia
and Kazakhstan.
The former left the Union the following day,
on December 12.
That was the end of the USSR and the beginning
of the Russian Federation.
[gentlemen titanic].
It’s not over yet.
With the exit of Russia, Kazakhstan became
the Soviet Union.
Yep.
For 4 days, until it declared itself an independent
republic on December 16, 1991, Kazakhstan
was basically the Soviet Union.
Oh great Kazakhstan, thank you, you created
a nightmare that even Lenin would never have
dared to dream.
I've been wanting to make this video for almost
a year, I tried 3 times previously but I always
gave up.
Summarizing the reasons for the collapse of
the Soviet Union in a 30 minutes video was
unthinkable.
Yet here we are.
Thanks to all of you for listening to me until
the end.
See you in the next episode.
Ciao!
On a very symbolic day, Christmas 1991, the
flag of the Soviet Union was pulled down from
the Kremlin's flagpole once and for all.
It was the end of an era that had lasted almost
70 years.
That evening pretty much every tv news broadcasted
live the resignation speech of the last secretary
of the Soviet Communist Party: Mikhail Gorbachev.
The first international reaction was that
of the US President George Bush Senior who,
for three times, described the event as America's
definitive victory over communism.
However, the question that many asked themselves
at the time was: how had it been possible
to get to that point?
The collapse of the Soviet Union was a sequence
of causes.
Internal and external, old and rotten, all
typical causes of a crippled system, magnified
by a sequence of major errors.
To discuss the collapse we must go back a
few years earlier, to November 1982.
Gorbachev wasn't yet the General Secretary
of the Communist Party.
That role was held by Jurij Andropov.
To be honest, the idea of "restructuring"
the Soviet Union did not start with Gorbachev.
But with Andropov.
Many in Russia were saying: if only Andropov
had lived a little longer, the USSR would
have survived.
Well, when he was appointed by Brezhnev as
his successor, Andropov was aware that he
was inheriting a Soviet Union full of problems.
By 1982, the Soviets were at war with Afghanistan,
détente with the West had failed, and Reagan
- an anti-communist champion - had ascended
to the White House.
In Eastern Europe, things weren't any better:
in Poland, workers were demanding a decrease
in food prices and, with the help of dissident
intellectuals, they had founded a movement
of revolt, Solidarity, which in the early
eighties already had millions of members.
The problems, however, were not "fresh" ones:
the USSR had many open questions since its
foundation, and one of these can be ascribed
to one single word: historical instability.
Since the time of the Revolution, Socialism
in Russia claimed to be able to modernize
a nation that, unlike Western Europe, was
still trapped in economic and political chaos.
It was like playing a strategy video game:
pick the USSR and you get a starting handicap
compared to other Western nations.
This starting handicap generated an immature
and unripe condition for the communists in
power, which made them force the stages of
a modernization process that had taken centuries
in the West.
To put it in even more basic terms that will
piss off any chef living in Italy, they wanted
to make pasta by boiling it in still lukewarm
water.
For some, the Soviet Union was created on
unstable foundations: an economy torn apart
by the incapacity of the imperial government,
working classes that were really still underdeveloped
and the absence of really decisive cultural
movements.
This condition of intrinsic failings of the
system, would persist throughout the whole
Soviet history.
Sure, with Stalin, heavy industrialization
and increased centralization brought changes
in the economy, they were a decisive impulse
to transform the Soviet Union into a nation
no longer backward, the second most industrial
nation in the world, yet the latent problems
didn't disappear, they only festered: the
majority population were no longer peasants
but workers.
Goodbye, Kulaks.
And with both Stalin and his successors Krushev
and Brezhnev, the economy was dictated by
a single key word: intensity...
when in fact the Soviets needed the opposite,
extensivity.
I’m not sure if this word exists in English.
To beat the West, the USSR adopted the mantra
of quantity over quality.
Although far from the American model, the
Soviet one would always be based on a "Fordist"
conception, let's say, where almost everyone
ended up in a factory working to contribute
to the huge production of materials, first
for war and then for civilian use.
And it remained so, even when in the rest
of the Western world, in the 80s, the arrival
of a new technology began to be foreseen:
information technology.
As promoters of a socialist model, the big
problem of the Soviets was being immediately
subjected to a very strong political isolation
and economic embargoes by that advanced part
of the world, the West.
The Soviet Union was indeed autonomous, but
ended up being a separate universe on its
own.
In the 80's, Andropov was the first to realize
that in order to modernize the Soviet economy
there were a need for money and knowledge
that was abundant in the West.
This idea obviously didn’t diminish the
value and the quality of many Soviet scientists,
but it rather diminished the immobility that
for decades marked the Communist Party.
As Andropov confessed in 1981 to Erich Mielke,
head of the Stasi - the East German secret
service: "The Americans seem to have unlimited
money".
Andropov had a point: NATO, Japan and the
Arab states of the Gulf contributed to financing
the American debt and its state funds, including
military spending; on the other hand, the
Soviet Union had a whole series of socialist
states that depended exclusively on subsidies
from Mother Moscow.
The isolation of the socialist countries had
contributed to making it clear to everyone
that it was capitalism that was dictating
the rules of the game, and the fact that with
détente in the 1970s the Soviet Union had
taken up the idea of opening a dialogue with
the United States, and thus knocking on the
door of those who controlled the capitalist
market, was - to use the words of Eric Hobsbawm
- the beginning of the end.
The first signs of weakness in the Soviet
Union appeared in 1979, when the international
markets were hit by a very serious oil crisis.
The wave fell with all its power on the Soviet
budgets that relied heavily on the export
of gas and crude oil.
The USSR was in fact the first oil producing
nation, with more than eleven million barrels
per day).
But it was another energy crisis that messed
up the game, not that of 79 but that of 73.
In that year, a West without oil decided to
renew itself technically and scientifically
so to make itself less dependent on crude
oil exporting countries and at the same time
find new ways of earning money; Russia, instead,
was satisfied to export oil to Western countries
and had no incentive to innovate itself.
At a meeting in 1982 Andropov denounced a
very disturbing fact: the Soviets were importing
more and more food such as grain and meat
from foreign countries.
Andropov said "I don't wanna alarm you," "but,"
he continued, "in the last few years we have
wasted billions of rubles.
Strong words, strong words from a strange
man, though in reality he was right, because
instead of using oil revenues to invest them
in technology and knowledge for development,
the Soviet Union used them to do what it should
not do: import food - that it could produce
very well by itself - and give subsidies to
its puppet states.
The United States did nothing but say thanks.
With the oil crisis in 79, the Russians found
themselves with no money left to pay for food
imports.
At that point what did they do?
They started borrowing money from Western
foreigners themselves.
The first to experience the mechanism of debt
on their own skin were the countries of Eastern
Europe, the Baltics but especially Romania,
Poland and Hungary, where the need to repay
foreign debt increased social unrest, which,
in turn, led to popular uprisings that slowly
brought Eastern Europe away from Soviet control.
The first countries to incur debts with the
International Monetary Fund were Yugoslavia,
which was no longer aligned with Moscow, and
then it was the turn of the friends in the
Warsaw Pact.
Already in 1970 Moscow found itself surrounded
by satellite states with negative budgets
and with pockets full of debts with the West.
When a group of dissidents created Solidarnosc
in Poland in 1980, Andropov became aware of
one thing: the inability to intervene militarily
as USSR had done with Czechoslovakia in 1968.
Moreover, the underlying problem wasn't tangible,
the problem was the absence of money.
As pointed out by historian Vladislav Zubok:
Poland had accumulated $27 billion in debt
to Western banks at very high interest rates
and, for its part, the Soviets did not have
the capital to repay the debts of the Poles.
The Russians were well aware of the implications
of this: their own satellite states had become
the weak links that risked blowing up COMECON,
the economic alliance within the Union republics.
In an investigation by Carl Bernstein, a journalist
known for having contributed to the unraveling
of the Watergate scandal in America, it was
reported that Solidarnosc was nothing more
than a tool in the hands of the United States
and financed by the italian bank Banco Ambrosiano
– in connection with the Vatican - to undermine
the USSR from within.
Nothing new on the Western front: Actually
the exact quote from the book is “All quiet
on the Western Front”.
it's just that in Italian we say that way
and I translated it literally.
Mamma mia.
the Vatican hoped to take root not only in
the very religious Poland but also in the
rest of Eastern Europe; and the United States,
well, needless to say: they wanted to win
the race.
As Bernestein reported, the U.S. embassy in
the Polish capital of Warsaw had in fact become
the CIA headquarters on the other side of
the Iron Curtain.
Undoubtedly, in Poland there were already
discontents, the citizens were very suffering,
otherwise it would have been impossible for
the western secret services to create such
massive riots out of nothing.
The use secret services was common on both
sides; nuclear weapons forced to act in the
background.
And speaking of nuclear armaments, there are
those who say that the arms race and the military
spending budget contributed to the Soviet
imbalance.
According to Mark Harrison, professor and
expert in Economic History, it was not military
spending that endangered the Soviet economy.
In terms of numbers, the active personnel
in the Soviet Union in the 80's amounted to
more than 5 million and 12% of the GDP was
dedicated to the budget for the war industry;
in comparison, the maximum that the United
States had done was in 1963, when they allocated
9% of GDP.
The United States, having a greater number
of allies at its disposal and therefore more
resources to draw on, could tolerate with
more ease this competition which, at the end
was aimed at frantically bleeding the Soviet
coffers, something that the Secretary of State
George Schulz himself would later admit.
In the 80's, when Reagan threated the USSR
with the installation of the Euro missiles,
the Soviets had to intensify their efforts
by running after advanced technologies and
creating an arsenal of more than 6000 nuclear
warheads, a huge strain for the weak Soviet
economy that generated irreparable imbalances.
In fact, since Stalin took the leadership,
the Soviet economy had been based on a state
of permanent war and neurosis, and this had
pushed the Russians to prefer heavy industry
- first of all war and industrial machineries
- at the expense of consumer goods.
And as if that weren't enough, despite Kosygin's
unsuccessful attempts to reform the economy
in the 1960s, Soviet planning - which was
centralized and state-based - had serious
cracks in it: false and inaccurate information,
inflated production costs, excess materials
produced without accounting for the real quantities
needed, low labor productivity, low rhythms,
absenteeism, and poorly exploited labor.
All this only widened the gap with the overly
competitive capitalist world.
If you were a Soviet worker, whether you worked
hard 10 hours a day or not, that salary always
came.
So why make an unnecessary effort?
The same happened with the salaries of all
the professions (from doctors to engineers)
which, since Krushov in the 60's, had been
fixed at a predetermined ceiling beyond which
they rarely went.
It is logical that without the possibility
of economic progress, one does not have the
incentive to get better.
Practical examples such as these generated
over the decades a loss of confidence in socialism
by the Soviets.
In the 1970s and 1980s in Russia, as reported
by historian Zaslavsky, workers were passive,
indifferent, lacking ideals and driven by
purely consumerist behavior, a pessimism also
intensified by the failure of the invasion
of Afghanistan.
Society had entered a labyrinth of economic
and social crises.
The same Soviet companies, subsidized by the
State, did not aim at technological innovation
and investment, because nothing would change.
In a nation where little food, few medicines,
few clothes or household appliances were produced,
things were bound to get jammed up.
With the crisis of 1979, the distribution
of essential supplies became more and more
complex.
When, under Gorbachev at the end of the 1980s,
food prices conformed to those of the Western
free market, the damage was complete and empty
shelves in supermarkets became the norm in
Russia.
Another internal issue that had been building
up since the Fifties in the Soviet Union then
deepened the crisis of essential goods.
The Double Economy.
Today we would call it "the black economy",
a shadow economy, parallel to the state economy
and composed of transactions that went under
the scanner of the Soviet bureaucracy.
In short, the Double Economy deprived the
State of revenue, making it flow into the
black market.
Goods such as cars, for which there were very
long waiting lists, were an excellent opportunity
on which many bureaucrats speculated, by reselling
them on the black market at very high prices.
This involved any item: furniture, spare parts,
clothes and even houses construction.
The black market meant that, in addition to
money, materials and labor were being stolen
from the state.
Over time, all over the USSR - especially
the areas most remote from Moscow - an underworld
of businessmen - whom the historian Zubok
calls pseudo-capitalists - had formed.
These were real entrepreneurs with money,
materials and workers.
They contolled all of this under the table
to raise more money and earn more than the
standard salary offered by the State.
Konstantin Simis in his book "The Secret World
of Soviet Capitalism" states: "Under the socialist
surface lies a network of private companies.
Thousands of them produce sweaters, shoes,
sunglasses, cassettes with Western pop music,
handbags and many other goods.
The owners are both small businessmen and
multimillionaire family clans holding dozens
of companies."
When Gorbachev came to power in '85, no politician
or bureaucrat was exempt from this under-the-table
trafficking.
The underground economy, which in the 60's
was equivalent to 3% of the national economy,
in the 90's in the Soviet Union reached 13%.
Prostitution and drugs also contributed to
a large part of the Soviet underground economy.
It was in this illegality that corruption
and the Mafias found very fertile ground.
Already in 1974, among the highest Party officials,
the Moscow Mafia had profitable business relations.
With the fierce privatizations in the early
90's the Russian Mafia found a real treasure;
that was the period when organized crime became
the true master of the streets, the dispenser
of death and violence for millions of Russians
who fell into the Abìss of drug addiction.
. And unlike his predecessors who at least
tried to hide things, Gorbachev instilled
the idea of a lost war; he was the first to
say in his speeches that capitalism won, and
communism didn't.
Attitude of a true leader.
Many blamed the Soviet nomenklatura and bureaucracy
who enjoyed special privileges and lived as
if they were a class of their own.
State inertia, excessive bureaucratization
and the indifference of Party members had
created a huge gap between citizens and politics.
The politicians themselves were so old that
they were referred to as a "gerontocracy,"
a government of elders bloated by nepotism
and cronyism.
And clearly when the old guys are in power,
all gathered into one party, they only care
about keeping that power until they die.
What about improving the economy?
Pff who damn cares?
In the Soviet Union there were two nomenklatures:
the political-administrative one, which permeated
the single Party in Moscow, and the economic
one made up of military, intellectuals and
business managers.
That the two sides were separated was not
a good thing.
Because when the central state - hence the
bureaucrats in Moscow - increasingly weakened
by the scarcity of money and consumer goods
began to lose relevance and influence in the
country, the power passed more and more into
the hands of the economic nomenklatura, that
is those who actually held the real resources
of the country: directors who managed industries,
estates and mines, the same ones who later,
with the fierce sell-off of the best national
companies, would turn into multi-billionaire
oligarchs.
In the liberal years of Gorbachev, the "economic
nomenklatura" chose to play with intelligence,
opening private companies and joint ventures
with Western partners, by giving them valuable
information previously kept by party bureaucrats.
And that wasn’t all: they also offered most
of their resources that the Soviet Union enjoyed
in abundance, such as oil and gas.
Everything officially started with the famous
Perestrojka, literally "the reconstruction".
Perestroika proved one thing: that the breakup
of the USSR, before Gorbachev, was not a foregone
conclusion.
Gorbachev - who is still alive and is 90 years
old - has yet to be fully analysed by historians.
For the moment I will always remember him
for his awkward commercial [...] Essentially
with that appearance which was paid 1 million
dollars, Gorby implicitly admitted in front
of everyone that consumerism was superior
to the ideology of its own party.
The funny thing was that Gorbachev always
invoked Lenin's name in his rallies, he considered
him a mentor, but perestroika, initially presented
as something revolutionary, ended up becoming
the opposite, the dismantling of the whole
system.
The slogan was "acceleration", recovering
the gap with the West.
But in order to do so, Gorbachev implemented
his reforms on the basis of two conditions
that would have got Lenin's hair fall - at
least the remaining ones: de-statalization,
i'm not sure if this word exists in English,
and privatization.
According to some historians, Gorbachev acted
consciously, he wanted to dismantle the Soviet
system piece by piece, to embrace the dogmas
of economic liberalism, deceived by the benefits
of economic exchange with the West.
For others, Gorbachev was simply an idiot
who had no idea how to lead a country.
He instead admitted that he was convinced
that it wasn’t possible to reform the country
without first dismantling it, making it transparent
and free from the maniacal control of state
censorship, hence the concept of Glasnost'.
Glasnost was in fact the sounding board of
the disaster of perestroika, because the media
began to talk about those problems in Russia
that were under the eyes of all but no one
could mention: alcoholism, lack of food and
crumbling housing.
And speaking of alcohol: the drinking habit
of Russians is well known, to the point of
being a social plague.
Gorbachev thought it was time to eradicate
the problem by implementing an anti-alcohol
policy.
The catch was, however, that alcohol taxes
guaranteed the state a sum of about six hundred
and sixty-six million dollars.
However, the Gosplan, the State Planning Committee
- under pressure from Gorbachev himself - cut
off that source of revenue, raising drink
prices and prosecuting those caught in a...
well, miserable state.
Nonetheless, the ban didn't take into account
a detail: the black market.
The vodka that became a luxury good ended
up again "m3rachiulusly" resold through the
back door.
The financial disaster was quick to come:
sales of vodka dropped from 54 billion rubles
in 1984 to 11 billion in 1986.
In Gorbachev's mind, however, there were no
issues: this is it, in 5 years we'll heal
USSR.
Gorbachev reasoned by taking as a model what
happened in the 30s: at that time, the USSR
had begun to modernize thanks to the construction
of industries and plants erected by Western
companies that, on commission, had also trained
Soviet engineers and workers from scratch.
One example above all was the American architect
Albert Kahn, who joined the Kremlin's consulting
team for the construction of more than five
hundred industrial plants; another example
was the General Electric, which oversaw the
construction of the hydroelectric power plant
on the Dniepr River.
Instead, Gorbachev's mistake was to channel
money into existing state enterprises, not
to create new ones.
The old leaders were conservative, unwilling
to innovate.
And that's why much of the equipment that
had been purchased in the West was never used
in the old plants.
Brilliant.
Anyway, whatever plans Gorbachev and his team
of economists had for the long term...
well, the Chernobyl nuclear disaster in April
86 erased them altogether.
The flight of hundreds of thousands of people
from the surrounding areas evoked scenarios
from World War II.
According to the head of the economic department
Nikolai Ryzhkov, the cost of the Chernobyl
disaster for the first month alone was 8 billion
rubles.
To paraphrase Ryzhkov, Chernobyl delivered
a devastating blow to the Soviet economy.
People began to whisper that it was the " tainted
leader", Gorbachev, to bring bad luck... he
was called in that disdainful way because
of the visible spot on his forehead.
Gorbachev did not make himself very popular,
as he kept the entire Russian population in
the dark about the disaster for many days.
Apart from Chernobyl, Gorbachev went on with
his Perestroika, and what were the results?
Terrible.
Perestroika liberalized overnight a Soviet
economy that was planned from the beginning,
it was a devastating blow.
First, government officials approved the creation
of "free" prices, no longer controlled and
set by the state.
Only 4% of the citizens approved this maneuver.
The result?
A race to the top of basic necessities and
a hyperinflation that in 1992 would have touched
peaks of Two Thousand Six Hundred %. Money
was rationed and in its place a sort of "consumer
card" was introduced, they were sheets of
paper worth various amounts of rubles, with
which citizens could make purchases without
using cash money.
When they found a piece of bread after hours
standing in line, Russians could count themselves
lucky if they could buy a half-pound loaf
of bread for 6 dollars, compared to an average
monthly salary of fifty dollars.
Although the Soviet standard of living until
then had always been at least a third lower
than that of Westerners, citizens noticed
the difference with respect to previous times:
crime, especially the mafia, was lower and
there was a general sense of greater security.
Whether this was real or not is another story.
With Perestroika there was a free-for-all
for those who wanted to do business with large
foreign multinationals, an incentive from
which stemmed a whole series of speculation
and fake sales, like the ones of the strategic
Soviet mining companies at symbolic prices.
On top of that, there was the Issuance of
new currencies for all the republics of the
Union.
This increased the confusion of internal transactions
and trade.
In addition, the so-called "property law"
of 1990, which removed the state from ownership
of key industries, generated 2 million unemployed
nationwide, a figure never seen before.
And as we know, an unemployed population use
more and more alcohol and drugs, to say the
least.
By 98, the Russian economy, in the hands of
mobsters and foreign entrepreneurs, would
have been almost completely halved from 1990
figures, going from a GDP of five hundred
and ten billion to a GDP of two hundred and
seventy.
Food prices had doubled, and wages were less
than half.
While, typhoid, cholera and other diseases
had reached epidemic proportions in the country.
It was as if the entire nation had suddenly
gone back 80 years.
Some, such as historian Stephen Cohen, have
called this achievement the result of a particular
phenomenon, Gangster Capitalism.
The opening up to international markets also
encouraged the arrival of private banks, which
replaced the monopoly of the State Bank.
Soviet debt to Western banks jumped from twenty
seven point two billion dollars in 1985 to
forty billion $ in 1986.
Wanting to reform things too quickly also
invested the political front.
Gorbachev knew that the Party - and its members
- were the operational core.
If he wanted to change the Union structure,
the only way was to strip Party members of
their various Departments and deprive them
of their powers.
With a series of reforms Gorbachev did just
that, he took away the Party's decision-making
monopoly.
In doing so, however, it was like beheading
the State, it was a political suicide, in
all respects.
Without a head - the State - the body (the
Soviet Union) suddenly stopped working, a
bit like unplugging a device.
At that point, all it took was a little push,
an international event of great impact that
could maybe break up the entire Eastern bloc.
Oh, yeah, how silly, this already happened
in 1989: --- With the symbolic fall of the
Berlin Wall, like a domino, all the Soviet
republics, starting with the Baltic ones,
broke away one after the other in the wake
of the independence euphoria that horrified
the Russian nationalists.
And nationalism was the final card, the ace
of spades that would close the game.
The first to realize that the rules of that
game were changing, was Boris Yeltsin.
Like an old fox, Yeltsin exploited the frustrations
of the most radical communists and some of
the members of the secret service to break
away from Gorbachev's wing, dress up as a
populist leader, go into opposition, and support
a coup against Gorbachev in 1991 in the capital
Moscow.
The images of him getting on the tank would
go around the world, angering the most dissatisfied
people who were fed up with Gorbachev's policies.
The coup failed immediately, because obviously
there was no longer a state.
It must be said that 70% of the population
wanted to maintain the Soviet Union, the referendum
on the preservation of the USSR in 1991 clearly
demonstrated this.
But these were not Yeltsin's plans.
Yeltsin had all the popular support to be
able to obscure Gorbachev, take away his remaining
consensus and force him to resign at the end
of August.
In November of the same year Yeltsin would
issue a decree with which to make illegal
any activity of the Communist Party and dissolve
once and for all the Soviet State.
On December 11, 1991 only two of the 15 Soviet
republics were still part of the Union: Russia
and Kazakhstan.
The former left the Union the following day,
on December 12.
That was the end of the USSR and the beginning
of the Russian Federation.
[gentlemen titanic].
It’s not over yet.
With the exit of Russia, Kazakhstan became
the Soviet Union.
Yep.
For 4 days, until it declared itself an independent
republic on December 16, 1991, Kazakhstan
was basically the Soviet Union.
Oh great Kazakhstan, thank you, you created
a nightmare that even Lenin would never have
dared to dream.
I've been wanting to make this video for almost
a year, I tried 3 times previously but I always
gave up.
Summarizing the reasons for the collapse of
the Soviet Union in a 30 minutes video was
unthinkable.
Yet here we are.
Thanks to all of you for listening to me until
the end.
See you in the next episode.
Ciao!